welcome to this video yeah this is a
book review again and yeah I'm also
fulfilling up a request here because I
got a request to do a book review about
a non opening book this is of course
very much justified too because the
opening is of course an important part
of chess but certainly not the most
interesting part to read books about
yeah the book I'm reviewing today is
some so I need to get it out of a very
nice book I must say very very much like
to to read Lots
pillock the large parts of parts of this
book it's um it's brand-new just
released and it is some written by Judy
porygon
the number one female player in the
world for now 23 years if I'm not
mistaken maybe it's already 24 years so
she's certainly an absolute record
holder and any kinds of sports I cannot
imagine some other yes sport or similar
activity where one person would be
number one for 24 years um okay you've
got Laska with world champion and so on
but they were narrating the censor and
such back in the day so um
yeah she's of course a very one knowing
player so I don't think I need to do a
very extensive introduction here what I
can do is sum I can have a brief look in
this book which lists very briefly on
two pages only and it could have been
much longer but on two pages only some
of the accomplishments on here she
defeated all world champions that she
played besides Kramnik she has a
terrible score against Kramnik and never
beat him but he she beat all world
champions and yeah of of the modern year
on which that she acts
he had the chance to defeat she never
played Botvinnik for instance she
certainly played Fisher and event games
but she doesn't tell in the book what
what were the results then and for
instance she be done on more than once
and Kasparov
at least in rapid chess and Karpov all
said tournament games and so on
she won yeah obviously a large amount of
tournaments
it's it's endless quite remarkable ISM
that she won two youth World Youth
Championships under 12 and under 14 but
in the overall section so including
including a male competition not the
gods only competition and those
tournaments under 12 and under 40 now
are very very tough if you look in if
you have some time on your hands then
search for the results of those some
tournaments you you'll find amazing
amazing list of future stars in there I
remember that that the World Youth
Championship 1992 was in the town where
I live in Duisburg Germany and the under
10 section back then was won by Luke
Machine McShane the head of Alexander we
shook and Etienne back row so this is a
knee low average of to 740 or so
nowadays so winning there was some under
12 and under 14 is something really
really difficult um yeah but what about
this book this is said the first book in
serious actually of three books and the
serious is called jeu de praga teaches
chess and this is the first interesting
point it's not a simple my best games
collection or just yeah sort of typical
chess biography and some
it's rather interestingly structured as
it is not describing her career in a
chronological order but rather groups
the content into into themes first I
need to mention that there are two
volumes only the first volume now has
been released the other ones will come
out I think next year maybe one even
this years it's a matter matter of month
I guess it's in the pipeline but not not
finished or not released and this first
volume has got the subtitle II how I
beat Fischer's record which means it's
about her career until age 15 career
until age 15 sounds funny I think and
when she actually beat Fisher's record
at becoming the youngest Grandmaster
ever Fisher had set this record in 1958
if I'm not mistaken at becoming
Grandmaster at 15 and she beat it by
about two or three-month um and this is
some the timespan that is featured in
this book featured in this book and it
is group that's mentioned not in I don't
know in years month arm or something
like that but in themes I can tell you
some of the themes first one is caught
tricks which is very entertaining a
tweet she's always been known for being
a technical yeah wizard at the board
really whether this is wrong word which
yeah which but this doesn't sound right
yeah well she's technically yeah
exceptionally gifted and there are lots
of nice examples of of tactical play in
this chapter
yeah further chapters are mating net
trapping the queen resolution sook
improving peace placement pong play a
leading development attacking the anchor
for king
attacking without Queens things like
that so I'm the example some from this
time period a nicely grouped into these
themes and first time ser was a bit
skeptical because this is a rather
unconventional approach to that kind of
yeah
autobiographical best games collection
um kind of book but it works really well
and this is due to to the way the games
are yeah presented here and I must say
I'm absolutely amazed about the detail
that has went into the the games and the
commentary yeah I cannot pronounce this
word correctly the comentary commentary
about the games because in contrast to
lots of modern books there is really
lots of text in there there are lots of
very very thorough explanations my moves
have been played what are the ideas
behind the moves and so on so it's very
nicely done you can really read this and
you're not kind of overwhelmed by tons
of variations on this dreaded informated
symbols like widest slightly better
black is slightly better with
compensation there's real text in there
so you can really read through with the
games and play them even on a real
chessboard and trying to learn the the
kind of ideas that have been behind the
moves and this is why I enjoy this book
so much because nowadays you're very
often have this very I don't know
clinical kind of comments on chess games
where people very much rely on computer
evaluations and just put out there white
is slightly better and black a slightly
better and sometimes they don't even
give some some vague explanation why
one side is slightly better there's even
the tendency to to give evaluations in
this computer digits like plus 0.3 plus
0.7 and this is the complete opposite to
this book it really has lots of text
explanations and this is also why this
general concept of and the title teeth
Judit Polgar teaches chest actually fits
to this book because it has so many
nicely nicely presented games um I can
really recommend this book
wholeheartedly it's really great to
great read in addition what I like very
much is there are lots of pictures in
there and I guess lots of pictures from
the poga and archives that have haven't
been published before there's some real
gems in there I mean there are so many
pictures but I absolutely love tm1
pictures and very nice with the Julian
son I would a sister Susan she's caught
now Susan since he and she moved to the
u.s. official program playing blitz
against Michael tall in 1986 in Moscow
with Judith watching she's 10 years
older than Ken Valley yeah reach the
table to to watch the game it's just
great and also there's a picture here of
chewed it with with Bobby Fischer from
1992 she was 16 back then and met fish
and Budapest
it's a ton of nice pictures also and
there's gamba she are not visiting the
the paga home they had a really early
meeting when when when Arnold was just
yeah about 20 years old and he played
blitz against Judah at age 12 I guess
quite quite funny and so there's a there
are although also those kind of stories
and nice things that you that you can
learn
about the history of the toga system but
it's nicely combined with with them with
the chess content um I don't want to
make this review too long I think my
early reviews have been very long at
times so um what I want to do is I want
to finish quickly with them an example
very very simple in comparison example
but but I simply liked it and it's quite
quite nice to see that this example here
that Judy Pogo plate is from 1984 when
she was just an eight years old and it's
quite nice what she what she did here to
do it to the opponent um I have a look
at this position here which is on the
board for ten minutes now I mean
probably you have thought a bit about
this while I was um telling things about
the book um yeah
why does a queen down but she's got a
rook of course and and two very strong
bishops here on b3 and g3 by the way the
opponent in his name is said not known
it's a the nicely
yeah placed NN here I guess it simply
got lost them in in those in those yes
but it's um yeah it's clear that white
needs to get through the King blacks
King is very every year and the first
move was full age to f1 there's no other
way to get to the king yeah this was
also the the text TM you need to get to
the king yeah and now we see that black
really asana in a crossfire of pieces so
what should legs King do like went to g7
of course you can also think about king
yet here but
look here why should Black's Queen go
now
for example after this there should be
six end the Queen gets lost and White
has some yeah decisive material
advantage so there's not much choice
black needs to go to g7 and now we've
got the root of seven check looks normal
and not black went to h8 of course the
only other move they're only two
playable moves really a Sun King here
but then this also needs to win for
white for example so check here King G 6
and then Bishop takes here it's simply
too much and White has also this check
coming up and the Queen doesn't have any
cut squares even let's say here check on
f6 King g7 and now the very nice move -
should be 5 you see that what pieces are
completely dominating the position after
this last idea with this White has this
intermediate check and then captures the
Queen afterwards but this wasn't played
black one - like when - to h8 and if you
want you can stop the video now and try
to work out the continuation here for
yourself it's not terribly difficult but
it's very nice so I'll be silent for a
couple of seconds if you want to stop
the video alright the solution is so
nice Jesus x36 check it takes on g6 so
Bishop e5 check King g8 the only move
there's nothing else
and now very nicely look every check and
this is just it's just very nice all
those pieces are working together
perfectly and black has nothing better
than King age seven and rook age three
checkmate
very nice yeah it's always look at look
at the way this this this unfolded rook
f1 check
oops it doesn't want to give me okay I
can so I can put them on the board again
first giving up the exchange here to to
have to check on the FL and then this
kind of finishing combination basically
you need to see this on the first move
and she was eight years old at the time
this is this is quite something there
there even more impressive examples of
of her play at age eight and nine and
sometimes you really don't know what to
say if you see the moves played at such
an age and I must must add that if you
if you look now this at this statistics
of the youngest grandmasters ever there
now about twenty players who made it
Madden at a younger age than Judah did
in 1991 but this is absolutely not
comparable I think in modern times with
the way she played back then she would
have easily made it at least two years
earlier I mean back then you only had
you just had much much lower amount of
grandmasters around and you didn't have
the chances to make those Grandmaster
norms she she when she shot to the first
rank in the world and the woman World
Rankings in 1989 she already had 2500
you know and was clearly Grandmaster
strength but she still took two years to
the Grandmaster norms simply because
they're there want some money
tournaments where you could make them
nowadays you have tons of tournaments
each I mean all kinds of even small open
tournaments offer the chance and this is
not comparable to to these days where
you really needed to to to get the the
opponents to to even have the chance to
make the norm even if you had the the
playing strength clearly you needed to
get this done and it's a simply no
comparison whatsoever um yeah a great
book because of the absolutely wonderful
on way the games are presented here with
those nice explanations it's really
nicely done and I must say I'm I was
thinking about what kind of level of
players this might approach this book I
think even if you have generated like
fifteen sixteen hundred you can take
lots of lots of good things from this
book because of the very nicely
complemented games and the text is very
insightful of course it's also a very
nice book for for higher rated players I
mean I think for those target group the
following books would be more
interesting even because simply she
would have better a position in the game
so there's not such a huge gap in
playing strength lots of these examples
arm when she played like in youth
tournaments or yeah but she even really
completely outplayed grandmasters at age
10 and 11 what can you say so it's it's
great content and I'll post the link
also in the description so that you can
get more information on about the book I
can only recommend it and
um yeah hope you have the chance to to
get this book to get this book down soon
I think it's just released and may might
not be available on already at some some
countries okay enjoy this book and
thanks for watching this video